[Music]
recently married congratulations thank
you I knew had a lot of fun at your
wedding and and and and things got a
little out of hand
what did you do that we got a little you
know what I had such a great day and it
was it was the only one regret I do have
I think it was probably the adrenaline
and I maybe I started drinking a little
bit too early so I can't remember an
awful lot after midnight and I was
talking to my wife the next morning and
I was like I was okay though I was I
didn't like make a fool of myself or
anything in front of and she said no you
were fine you were great you were
gregarious and all of that I was
surprised that you wore the crown for so
long you got at least you wore a crown
at one point it would seem so yeah
and at the time I was like no no no you
were you were you were in the square I
can't remember wearing I think you're
making that up just make me feel but
then she she sent me on a picture yeah
we have the picture this is you wearing
a crown
all we really have time for you you had
some other pictures but I don't think we
have time wait your wife is beautiful
she's gorgeous